un peu meilleur jeune et meilleur avenir
anthony
ok oui messieurs merci merci beaucoup
très bien alors vous est né en 1926 à
newark dans le new jersey votre père
s'appelait daniel levy tx10 dany lévis
et voeckler ça plairait hohrodberg alors
vos parents étaient des comédiens sur
scène dans ce qu'on appelle le bortsch
circuit tu sais quoi le grand circuit
c'est quoi le bortsch equity et new york
state who use to go pro de sa main c'est
les montagnes du quatre îles au nord de
new york où les gens allaient passer
l'été au maine
en voilà et vos parents joués sur scène
dans ces endroits là des choses
fright night oh oui ah ouais il faisait
des choses cette nuit par des choses
cinq jours par semaine dit elle
quand vous avez commencé sur scène vous
faisiez brodeur new star d'high we you
remember the yes vous souvenez de sa
mémé et sharon stone
gbagbo
ouais
lewis chanter à l'âge de 5 ans sur scène
quand ils et elles étaient dans les
cases avec ses parents brothers can use
père d'anne c'est-à-dire brodeur est ce
que tu peux me donner un 10/10 hans quoi
parce que parce que les vrais loups et
là les chemins de fer était terminée il
avait plus d'argent est ce que tu peux
me donner 10 cents c'est ce que vous
êtes chanter merci merci beaucoup battu
en 1939 puis nineteenth au final à l'âge
de 13 ans vous avez été exclu du collège
parce que vous avez battu le directeur
du collège bien parce que vous avez fait
une remarque antisémite oui mais pas de
vigo aux twingo par la fenêtre
vous avez dit vous avez dit jerry lewis
l'antisémitisme c'est une maladie comme
l'alcoolisme
hier un meeting des folios c'est une
maladie comme le racisme
albert riba time it j'aime mon coeur est
ouvert à tout le monde
huguette l'avis général mario arena si
vous traversez la vie d'une façon
magnifique si vous aimez les gens mais
vous étant d'en faire si vous ne les
aimez pas
alors qu'harry lewis pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme et perpétuer la mémoire
de la shoah en 1972
vous avez fait un film qui s'appelle le
jour où le clown pleura oui vous êtes à
la fois acteur et réalisateur
si une histoire extraordinaire c'est
l'histoire d'un clown allemande
anti-nazie arrêté par la gestapo et
emmené dans un camp de la mort hélas ce
clown est chargé par les nazis d'emmener
les enfants à la chambre à gaz en les
faisant rire pour qu'ils se rendent pas
compte de ce qui leur arrive
il dit qu'il le finira un jour oui parce
que ce film n'est jamais sortie n'est
jamais fini non point pour des raisons
sordide de raisons de droits des raisons
du rejet réseau de production des
raisons d'argent comme ça arrive parfois
que le producteur s'en va avec la caisse
mais un rien timide espérer de pouvoir
un jour récupérer les pellicules est
terminée quand vous avez vu le film de
bellini qui s'appelle la vie est belle
est ce que vous pensez qu'il avait été
au courant de votre projet puis
musulmane de fonds il était fort mais
dix étaient très proches de votre idée
quand même
bien
jerry lewis on a vu que vous allez bien
beaucoup mieux on va vous faire une
terre